Alyssa's backstage and Kevin is behind these walls
ready to repop the question in the most romantic way.
And Alyssa has no idea.
So should we bring Alyssa out? Okay.
(audience applauding)
Alyssa, come on out!
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Hi!
Hi.
How are you?!
I'm fine, how are you?
Oh, I'm so good.
So nice to meet you. Thank you for having us on.
Thank you so much for showing up.
Absolutely.
Happy Valentine's Day.
Happy Valentine's Day. (chuckles)
I love Valentine's day.
Me too. (chuckles)
Well, you've been married now for three years.
Yep, almost. It'll be three in August.
Three in August?
Mm hmm.
And will you tell us about your husband, Kevin?
Yeah, so he's really funny.
I think that's kind of what attracted me to him,
like originally.
He's hard working. He's a great dad to our kids.
Speaking of kids, your husband,
his proposal actually involved one of your children.
Yes. (chuckles)
Can you please tell me about that?
So he was down on one knee and his daughter, Kaylee,
was filming, and we were focusing on the moment.
And then we kind of looked at each other
because she started laughing,
and we didn't know why she was laughing until he got up.
And then we saw my son, Owen, who was at the time three,
and he was peeing behind Kevin,
and we had no idea.
(audience laughing)
Isn't that just so life?
Yes. (chuckles)
Like it's so perfect.
Also, you guys said you love to laugh,
and humor is everything.
Yep.
But why do you think you're here today?
To talk about being newlyweds?
Oh, okay.
Well, actually we have a little surprise for you.
Kevin actually wanted to do a little something
about that engagement situation.
So he actually asked us to get involved.
I hope you don't mind.
Kevin, are you there?
(gentle harp music)
Oh, my God. (laughing)
Am I getting up?
(indistinct) right there.
Oh, Okay.
Ali, from our initial introduction,
I knew you could be the one.
From our first date to the Ferris wheel.
(Alyssa laughing)
No tickets necessary will always be part of our journey.
(gentle harp music continues)
Kaylee, Owen, Olivia, and I appreciate you
more than anything in this world.
(Alyssa inhales deeply)
We may not show it all the time, but we do.
(gentle harp music continues)
I love you. (laughing)
Ali.
Oh! (gasps) Oh, okay.
Will you marry me again?
Yes. (laughing)
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
You want me to take this-
(faintly speaking)
Put it on? (laughing)
(audience applauding)
(Drew clapping)
(audience cheering)
(Kevin and Alyssa laughing)
Come on up here for a second.
(audience applauding)
We just wanted to provide you a nice,
beautiful safe space filled with flowers
and good energy and cool neon lights
and an extraordinary artist and music.
And also, Simon G. jewelry.
That is a very beautiful ring.
So that was sparkling like nobody's business.
(Alyssa laughing)
Did you guys see that?
I was like, "Is this thing glowing?"
(Kevin laughing)
(audience laughing)
It's so amazing.
They gave you this handcrafted beautiful diamond,
18 caret white gold ring.
And it really is stunning.
I did think it was lit from within.
So I also heard
that Kevin had to work through the entire honeymoon too.
Is that correct?
That's true.
(Alyssa chuckling)
It's been a working honeymoon.
Well, that's not fair.
We'd like to do
something about that too.
It was fun.
We are gonna send you
on a luxurious seven-night,
eight-day stay in Fijian-style bungalows
at Yasawa Island Resort
and Spa,
(audience applauding)
an all-inclusive luxury resort in Fiji!
I've actually never been to Fiji.
That sounds so amazing!
(Alyssa laughing)
And it includes meals and activities.
And you're also getting round trip airfare provided
by Fiji Airways.
So now you can have a real honeymoon.
(audience applauding)
(Alyssa and Kevin laughing)
I love that.
Every amenity
has been taken care of.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)